we have to help a guy that's in serious
trouble
we have a guy named mason who is
recently unplugged and married to a
single mom and he's asking now what
i am i am here to save you mason
okay
uh yeah i guess
i was really
very unhappy and kind of depressed the
last uh
couple years here and i didn't find you
first actually the first thing that i
read was no more mr nice guy
and that kind of like set off a lot of
bells for me i guess you figured out the
covert contract part
yeah then i kind of started going on
youtube and i found you and rolo and a
few other people and like
okay yeah i'm uh
i'm 30 years old
i'm in a relationship with a single mom
married to her okay we've been married
for
about six or seven years now jiminy kids
and uh he's been putting up with a lot
do you have any kids with her i feel
like now i'm kind of
when i when i originally got with her i
was in a really uh
different circumstance in life i will
stop you for a sec mason can you hear me
okay
yes okay do you do you have any kids
with her
one
okay so you have a kid with her and she
brought how many to the table
uh
three
she brought three to the table
from two different fathers yeah so now
you so now there's four kids and three
of them are not yours
correct do you live in a state where
you're on the hook for child support for
these three kids i'm in michigan and i
don't believe so here have you talked to
a family lawyer
no
okay so what's going on like what's the
problem right now in this uh marriage
um
lots of stuff i just
have felt like disrespected like a
second priority like i
settled for
way less than i could have had and then
also like i've been taken advantage of
and there's been a lot of like
me helping her you know helped her start
a business because she was working for
someone else and i
i started a business for her and
everything just seems to be there's no
gratitude for it or anything it's just
like what you know what can i get next
type of the situation
was she again
huh was she ever in your frame
i don't know when i when i met her i was
uh
very overweight i was broke i was i
didn't have an education
a completely different person and uh
and now you're getting overweight and
now you're not broke
yeah
and now she's got the full force of
family law behind her too right
yes
yeah have you read my book
so you so you got through the chapter on
single mommies right
yes
all right
um
you're a like you've taken a bunch of
ingredients and you've put it in a
blender and you've turned it on and now
you've got a [ __ ] shake basically on
your hands yeah and
you're gonna have to get through it like
like like this is a this is a lot so
what's the ideal outcome for you like i
can wave a magic wand and solve this
problem what does it look like for you
in like three years
um
i guess i i mean i've been off of like
any kind of a
dating market or anything so long i
don't know what that would
look like for me if i left this
situation um
30.
okay so i mean like you're thinking
about getting out of this marriage is
what you're saying
yeah but it's it would also be a pretty
pretty costly to me as far as
you know i own a house and
two vehicles and a business and
everything and i don't know what of that
she would get as well as
how custody would go with my daughter so
yeah well
how is she handling custody with the
other three kids with the two different
daddies right now like does she have
full custody yeah
she has full custody
of her daughter with the first one and
she has a shared custody with the
two boys from the second one
and and she's getting paid by both the
other dad's child support yes
yep
what you need my friend is a time
machine and a swift blow across the back
of the head so you so you don't make
this mistake but we don't have either
one of those things
um you need to like honestly dude like
like you've got to try to
get the frame back i mean you've got two
options essentially
option one is try to get the frame back
and run the course this relationship and
raise these kids and um you know if it
doesn't work out you know you can get
out when they're all adults and at least
she'll be off the child support um gig
but uh
why doesn't the um why doesn't the first
kid see the father right now
uh he's kind of uh
i don't think he's ever really made an
attempt to to be in okay so she's not
keeping the kid from the father then
no
how is she with the other father you
know the one that she shares custody
with is she keeping the kids is she is
she cordial is she difficult
they they share time like 50 50. um they
don't like each other they don't really
talk or anything but uh
yeah it's so i would say it's somewhat
like a business transaction there's no
nothing extra just you know drop them
off pick them up they don't really talk
to each other or anything like that
yeah how are the kids treating you know
they treat you well or they treat you
like an atm
uh
yeah that's part of it too i just i just
felt like uh
her kids don't have a lot of respect for
me and i also
you know my my last job i was i'd wake
up at six in the morning and the kids
were like
not respecting that with
being in my house and uh
she was not willing to get involved with
that when i would say something they
would whine to her and
would you for living man
uh right now i
actually
own a lot of real estate and so i left
my job and i make uh about 250 to 300k a
year and
and i'm very she doesn't make anything
close to that
ah she has a salon that i helped her
open and she makes decent money there
but
what's decent money
uh
over 100k but not much
okay
yeah you're gonna be in a bad spot if
you try to untie this knot i mean your
best bet is if you can fix things which
is gonna like well dude like i'll be
honest with you it's gonna be a lot of
work and i don't have time to explain
everything that needs to be done
um i mean if you want you can book a
private consult for an hour and we can
spend some time chopping up some ideas
i'll give you some recommended tools and
resources um i would probably
take a look at some of the stuff that
ryan stone has put out on frame and
marriages and long-term relationships
he's got something called the male
action plan m.a.p
um
and
the way that you're describing it right
now
uh it like it just sounds like dude like
i feel for you but i'm just gonna say
this like it just sounds like a total
[ __ ] shake so um you're gonna put a lot
of work in
i was gonna say she's also significantly
older than me and that's become an issue
too i feel like how old is she
about 12 years older than me oh dude
yeah
oh man
this is some [ __ ] [ __ ] you're
telling me here right now man
do you want to get out of this thing
for me it feels it feels like i'm kind
of trapped that's what it feels like and
i
it's it's gonna cost you it's gonna cost
you a pound of meat to get out of this i
can tell you right now
so i mean like you can either go through
the male action plan stuff that
rhinestone talks about try to fix
everything try to like get her back in
your frame put the kids in check
discipline them but you know like as i
talk about in the chapter about single
moms is they want you to have the
parenting responsibility but without the
authority right and it sounds like you
don't have any authority with these kids
yeah absolutely how old are the kids
uh so the the two boys are
um a eighth grade and ninth graders so
they're like 13 and 14. so they're
basically teenagers i mean like yeah
it's gonna come to blows if they think
that they can take you on right
there well she's she's
asian and her kids are pretty small i'm
like six foot two and like two thirties
so i don't know you're a big dude like
you look like a chat it's just that you
made some really bad choices in your
life man
i when i met her i was
like 70 pounds heavier i wasn't lifting
weights i was uh i had a super short
buzz cut all the time i was
broke i was about to be kicked out of
where i was living so yeah
yeah i got a totally different person
um if you want to deal with the exit
planning we shouldn't talk about it on
youtube um and it's going to take like
another five minutes of a conversation
so what i'd say is shoot me an email
and just say that you were the guy um
you know with said situation i'll work
something out for you
okay all right we'll do if you want to
do the exit if you want to try to fix it
then i'd say follow rhinestone look up
the male action plan
you know see if you can work on getting
the frame back in the marriage and
dealing with the kids and you know
putting them in check but um i'll be
honest with you man the way you're
describing it it's it's it's going to be
a lot of work for
a
woman that's 12 year old you know 12
years older than you and still gonna
look bad so i mean yeah it's up to you
like you let me know what you want to do
like you know where to find me right
yeah i'll uh i'll reach out to you on
email and i would uh delete your uh
youtube histories just so she doesn't
know that you're watching this [ __ ] and
perhaps catch it you know what i'm
saying
yeah
all right buddy
all right all right thank you
man
wow i wasn't expecting to hear that like
like it just said here in the private
chat that he was married to a single mom
and it was struggling i was like all
right well let's do it you know what's
going on here but that's this is a long
conversation man
like you can plan the exit on something
like that it's just it's it's going to
take some work and it's going to cost
you it's going to cost you a pound of
meat you know
there's going to be stuff that's going
to go sideways and
but there's stuff that you can do to
plan for it to sort of minimize it it's
it's man
that's a mess
you